everyone and welcome to another python 3
tutorial video uh this video is going to
be covering tkinter and actually it's
going to be the first part of a
five-part mini-series around tkinter
what t-cantor is is it's part of your
standard library in python and it's
going to work with tk which is going to
subsequently work with tcl tcl is what
we use to make windows
and we have a little bit of a wrapper so
basically what we have here is we've got
tkinter which is a wrapper around tk
which is kind of like a wrapper around
tcl for making windows and what's going
to allow us to do is kind of it's almost
like a high level uh
wrapper so to speak so
within about
tens or so lines we can create a window
it's a very basic window but we can
create a window and this window can be
resized it can be minimized maximized
and most importantly it can be closed
and this actually involves a lot of code
and a lot of logic that we won't have to
worry about actually coding ourselves
thankfully
so with that let's go ahead and get
started now so um
what you'll find is most people i think
um at least myself are gonna go from
tkinter
import
uh asterisk so this means import
everything from t can turn so aside from
like super basic windows or something
your typical you know fully functional
gui or graphical user interface when i
say gui it stands for gui graphical user
interface in case you didn't know
your typical window is going to use a
lot of different functions from tkinter
and so it just makes a whole lot of
sense to just import everything to me
anyway if you want you can
import individual things do what you
want anyway
so now what we want to do is we want to
make our window class now i know classes
confuse a lot of people you've got self
parent master all this stuff um i
understand that and that gets confusing
but uh just bear with me now so self
usually just something
self just
corresponds to
really you're
basically
um
when you pass an object through whatever
you know your class you call it you say
self and then you say you know the
parameters and all that you don't really
have to call itself itself either you
can call it anything you wanted you
could call it
bajoomba
and this would be totally fine it would
be really confusing to people but that
would be totally fine
it's just kind of like um
expected that you use the word self but
you don't have to so anyway i'm moving
along so we're gonna say class capital
window and then through window we're
gonna pass through frame now frame is
not something i've just made up uh we're
actually passing through the frame um
within tkinter so
i figure i guess i might as well show
you guys so if we go to computer c
34
lib
and we come down to tkinter
and we're going to open up our
initialization script here so edit that
and we will do a ctrl f so we're going
to find and then just type frame we'll
hit and then we'll go find that one two
three four
five six seven eight
nine 10 11
12 13 14
there we go i guess after 14 we finally
found what we were looking for so
looking for this the class frame and
then widget and so this is what we're
referring to when you type frame in
there
uh so i'm gonna move this out so this is
basically saying we're gonna we're
creating our window and with that window
we're making a frame and so the frame is
really what you think of as a window you
have a frame and then you have got
you've got like contents within it
um but
programmingly we call that a frame not
really a window so anyway now what we're
going to do is we're going to define our
initialization so define underscore
underscore init underscore underscore
and then through the parameters again
we're going to use self i know it's
crazy but we're going to use self and
basically we're going to say for now
master equals none so
um
now um
basically what we want to do is what
parameters we want to pass through our
frame class
and what we've basically set here is
this is our parent widget so this is our
main window and then we will put more
stuff within that window so now we're
going to say we're going to say frame
dot underscore underscore knit
underscore underscore
and then
self
again kobe joomba and master so again
we're just referencing this
initialization here okay
and already well i suppose actually we
didn't even have to do is master equals
numbers that's by default so in theory
we actually could probably get away with
just self uh just in itself um
anyway uh so that's our default which
makes sense but anyway moving along
uh so after we've d we've done our
define initialization then frame and
then we're actually gonna say
self.master
equals master so this is our main
uh
window so this is just basically we're
calling this the master widget okay
um
and that's going to be our mainframe
okay
mainframe i crack myself up okay so then
uh what we want to do is you know we
could do all kinds of other things but
what i think i'd like to do now is what
we're going to do is we're going to say
root equals t k
actually tk like that and this one we
actually do capitalize the t and that's
actually something that we're we're
importing basically from tkinter just
like we imported frame from tkinter
so
this is what it's doing is we're calling
this our root window and again uh we
could open up where was i
here
i don't think i want to be in it hold on
let's see
see if we can find it in here
define tk
okay well you'll have to take my word
for it it's in here
anyway
uh so that's a root window basically and
then what we're going to say is our app
for application equals
window referencing our window class and
then within that our frame is going to
be our root route
and then finally we're going to say root
dot main loop and this basically
initializes
um
and
generates our window for us so let's go
ahead and save and run that
and boom we have ourselves a nice little
tk window so as i said we can resize the
window
we can minimize the window we can bring
it back
we can maximize the window and it just
and we can move it around all that and
we can close the window so we can do all
these things uh with very few lines of
code i said ten initially we got one two
three four five six seven eight lines
that we were able to basically create
this window within eight lines now
naturally
that's not really the case because we
used quite a few lines
from tkinter
but that's the whole idea of using
tkinter is that it saves you from
writing you know hundreds of lines just
for that basic window just to pop up
and really i suppose you could break it
down it's probably more like thousands
of lines but anyway uh if we go right
down to machine code um
anyway so that's just a basic window now
obviously there's a lot of things we can
do with windows we need you know buttons
we can do
text you know right so if i scroll this
thing down you know we've got title of
the window we've got some menu options
buttons all this kind of stuff so that
obviously a lot of things that we we
might want to add
uh to this so
anyway so this is just a basic window in
the next video we're gonna be doing is
kind of adding on to this window um a
little bit so stay tuned for that if you
guys have any questions or comments up
to this point feel free to leave them
below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time